[Music]
wayne
is in san antonio hi wayne welcome to
the ramsay show
hey dave hello john how's it going man
going well what's up how can we help
well question uh we've got a 12 year old
contracting business here in central
texas
and i'm 58 years old and due to the past
year and a half with covid
and then we had five very extremely
difficult
talent stretching projects just right in
a row
and i'm tired ready to give up by my
my two problems that we're facing is
that one my business isn't sellable
without me and the the second is that
our son
a 22 year old wants the business
but i'm just not seeing the tools in
this toolbox right now
you know and my plan is is to
in the next four years i want to start
stepping out we'll do
mentoring and teaching and guiding as
needed
and then you know eight years boy i'd
kind of like to be gone out of here
but uh like i said i'm just not seeing
the tools in the
in the toolbox for our son yet
and i'm tired so
you're you're me and i understand you
say that you have eight years to develop
him
in your mind yeah so he would be 30.
he would be and you'd be 66
yep and that would be it'd be a gradual
phasing
between now and then um
uh with the final handoff of the baton
at that point
okay yeah somewhere in that 66 to
70 somewhere in there okay well
we do know he has one major tool desire
he does okay and you can work a lot with
desire as you know trying to light wet
wood is hard
yes it is what what tools do you think
he's lacking
he doesn't have the business acumen he's
22. he is
he doesn't even have hygiene acumen at
22.
he doesn't have dating acumen he doesn't
have hairdo acumen he didn't have a lot
of acumens he can't drive probably
right can i tell you i hear two
different problems here
i hear one you're looking at a 22 year
old
and it's hard for us to remember all of
us being 22
and the difference between 22 year old
john and 30 year old john
is is it's i mean that's those are two
completely different humans thankfully
and it sounds like you're gonna have to
mentor you're gonna be tired mentoring
and teaching your son
and you're gonna have to be letting go
i'm watching dave do this here and it's
just something to behold watching
somebody transition their business while
the car is still driving down the road
but the second thing is you mentioned
this several times
you're tired and turning the turning
looking down a decade from now and and
worrying about that
problem right this minute when you've
just gone back to back to back to back
to back on some major problems
man you're you're catastrophizing a
situation that i don't think has to be
catastrophized because
your body is cooked right now and is
there some ways you can get yourself
some peace
now do to be intentional about a break
about some rest about some rejuvenation
some
redeveloping your mission and then get
back in the game
and then begin a decade-long training of
your son it's the
it's the lombardi quote fatigue makes
cowards of us all right
you sound exhausted man it is
i it's been a long road okay so here's
the thing
there's only one thing from your son's
perspective
that would absolutely there's two things
it would absolutely disqualify him
from this process okay and i don't think
you're saying either one of those things
but i'll just put them out there
number one he's a person lacking in
character
he's a little twerp and he's not going
to get any better he's
has no integrity he's a jerk nobody
wants to be around him
nobody wants to mess with him i don't
either that's not what you said i don't
that's not the like
tool okay the second thing is if you
honestly believe
he does not simply have enough
intelligence to learn
and i don't think you're saying that
i think what you're whining about and
it's a fair wine by the way
is the distance between where you are
and where you got to get to and that
eight years is going to require a lot of
dead dadgum work and you're tired
but i think i think he can get there i
didn't hear anything disqualifying him
because whatever tools he needs business
acumen
you can be taught in eight freaking
years
if you have business acumen you could
teach someone business that's a medical
degree
right you could teach them
okay i think you've got an identity
challenge here because i think you have
wrapped you have worked real real hard
to build
a construction company in central texas
and now you are the guy that some of the
people in your community go to for big
projects and you've got a great identity
in the idea of trying to land that plane
where you're not a a pilot anymore
that's not that gets in your heart right
so i i i think you can do it and i know
you can't i
and and i think he can do it too i
didn't hear any disqualifiers in here
yet um now i would put on the table
that you know here's some clips you need
some clarity
if you're going to engage in this
process i would put on the table and and
i've done this with the ramsey
children that work here right and even
my daughter's
uh husband winston works here right runs
all of our real estate
um you don't get a pass because of your
name as a matter of fact you have to
bring it almost double just to be
respected
because of your name and so you know i'm
going to line up and teach
you this stuff and hand you this thing
but your part in it is you got to bring
it
you got to be game on you got to be
super responsible
you got to be super sensitive you got to
be thinking about every word that comes
out of your mouth because
everybody is watching you and to be
respected you're going to have to do
2x of everything
and he's got to say i'm going to bite on
that apple i'm doing it
so like rachel's selling books at the
back table at a seminar at 14 years old
that's the speech she got
you don't get to put his kick back put
your feet up play pokemon or something
back here in the back you get your butt
up to the table
belly up and you sell books take money
and smile
and tell those people you love them that
are walking up because you do
and by god you don't do that mean you're
going to have a problem later you got to
bring it 2x that's teaching business
acumen and customer service and
and respect and i'd love you to be a dad
who recognizes the blessing that for the
next eight years you're going to have
breakfast cups
so far every morning i mean every once a
week with your son every ev every week
for the next eight years
i was in a two-hour strategy session
with my son and his top leadership team
this morning
and we got to play business together it
was so freaking fun
what a gift that is some day i'm going
to miss that yeah it was really fun
this is the ramsey chat